hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on Luke universe comm thank
you and enjoy so in this video we're
going to continue our discussion of the
LDL receptor and how it's important in
hypercholesterolemia and atherosclerosis
so let's define atherosclerosis first
it's the thickening the thickening of an
arteries wall due to plaque buildup
plaque buildup
so normally an artery looks like this
we've got this little tube basically
that blood can flow right through and
eventually get to tissues that line the
capillaries okay so blood of course
carries oxygen in a bunch of nutrients
to these tissues okay so this is what
normally happens we have the blood going
through this is a normal artery now what
can happen is in the atherosclerosis
artery thorough sclerosis we could
basically have a plaque buildup in the
wall of the artery
so let's here's a plaque and this plaque
as you can see here it basically cuts
off the Bloods ability to flow through
the tube that is the artery so we got an
obstruction of blood flow here so these
plaques form due to high cholesterol
concentrations and LDL concentrations
LDL levels and that is called
hypercholesterolemia hyper cholesterol
amia to break down that word here hyper
means too much right too much
cholesterol obviously is referring to
cholesterol and LDL so si and LDL and
the email refers to the blood so this is
basically too much cholesterol and LDL
cholesterol in the blood
that's what hypercholesterolemia is and
of course these plaques build up because
of oxidized LDL being consumed by
macrophages to form foam
these foam cells build up in the wall of
the artery that get this plaque here
okay so that's something we talked about
previously so the question you know so
this this is bad right and the answer is
yes tissues need oxygen from blood as
well as other nutrients so if these
tissues do not get that oxygenated blood
what can happen is this thing called an
infarction infarction which is basically
tissue death due to no oxygen okay so
you might have heard the term myocardial
infarction which is based more commonly
known as a heart attack what that
basically is is that there are arteries
that line your heart that supply your
heart with oxygen your heart muscles
with with with oxygen as well the other
nutrients so those are those arteries
are called the coronary arteries and
those arteries when they supply your
heart this is a very simple drawing here
but the idea is that if these these
arteries kind of get obstructed for
their blood flow what could happen is
that the tissues that are that these
blood vessels are supplying might not
get enough oxygen and other nutrients
and if they don't get enough oxygen they
could die and if your heart muscles die
that's obviously really really bad
because your heart pumps blood through
your entire body and if it can't do that
then your tissues won't get oxygen or
any of the nutrients and you could die
from a heart attack so that's sort of
myocardial infarction it's this is
obviously something that's very very
serious this can also happen your brain
and that will be called a cerebral
infarction otherwise known as a brain
attack but more commonly known as a
stroke so both of these cases are
obviously very bad and you've probably
already heard of them but now you kind
of know what's going on here cerebral
infarction basically would happen same
idea right if there are blood vessels
that that are in your brain that supply
your your brain tissues with with oxygen
if they can't get oxygen into those
tissues those tissues can die and that
could lead to a stroke
so obviously this
not something that's Pleasant okay now
there's also a specific type of
hypercholesterolemia called familial
hypercholesterolemia or fh and it's a
genetic disorder characterized by high
LDL concentrations in the blood
okay so familial does that mean family
genetic so how what's going on there
well bet that basically means if its
genetic is that there's a problem with a
gene product right that might seem a
little redundant but gene products or
proteins right so something's wrong with
a particular protein that causes
familiar hypercholesterolemia that
causes us high cholesterol in the blood
in this case that specific protein that
is a that is the problem is the LDL
receptor so two things basically it can
be the case either there's no LDL
receptor being made so there's no LDL
receptor protein synthesis at all or
there's too few functional LDL receptors
in either case people with familial
hypercholesterolemia don't have it
either they don't have enough of this
receptor to take up LDL into the into
their cells so basically the take-home
point simply is that in familial
hypercholesterolemia LDL is not being
taken up by cells so what ends up
happening is that the LDL stays in the
blood so if it stays in the blood we
have a high environment to put high as a
high concentration of LDL on the blood
which of course we know is damaging
right because it can form the oxidized
LDL form cells and so on and so forth so
the question is how is this treated well
if an individual has no LDL receptors at
all and there are homozygote for this
trait they need a new liver and so in
that case transplants are necessary okay
but
just less LDL receptor which means just
not enough in that case of a
heterozygote what can happen is that
they would want to decrease the amount
of cholesterol in the cells and the
cells so as to increase uptake of
cholesterol from the blood right so
basically the idea here is to decrease
the amount of cholesterol in the cells
so that the cells can in fact take up a
cholesterol from the blood right and
specifically LDL cholesterol so there
are drugs that are called statins which
you mentioned before statins inhibit
hmg-coa reductase which we mentioned of
course was the committed step in
cholesterol synthesis so the idea here
is that if if we have this committed
step of cholesterol synthesis inhibited
there will be less cholesterol in the
cells which would allow an increase in
the uptake of cholesterol from the blood
into the cells this is important because
the receptors the LDL receptors are
synthesized on a need basis right so if
there's a lower cholesterol
concentration in the cell and that is
sensed what could happen is that that
means we're going to have more uptake of
the cholesterol because we'll have more
receptors made right and what that will
do is that if we're taking cholesterol
into the cell there's going to have
we're gonna have less cholesterol in the
blood less LDL in the blood okay so okay
so that means less LDL in the blood if
there's less LD on the blood that means
less the lower probability of oxidized
LDL s forming and being taken up by
macrophages and that there's less of
those being taken up we're going to have
less foam cells forming which means less
plaques would form which means we'd have
less atherosclerosis and less
cardiovascular
zees so that's the idea there hopefully
fall owed that train of thought there
okay
so that's how that's why it statins are
so important in this treatment lifestyle
changes are also considered sometimes I
with individuals who have a genetic
disorder they have to sometimes have to
be extra careful about their diet and
exercise but really everyone is always
encouraged to diet and exercise because
those are just healthy things to do and
yeah so I hope that video makes sense
and again to be clear none of this is to
be taken as medical advice I am NOT a
health care professional if you
genuinely have any concerns or questions
about your health definitely consult
your physician anyway I hope that video
was helpful in looking at this from an
academic perspective thank you for
watching thanks for watching be sure to
LIKE comment subscribe and don't forget
to share the video of anyone who you
think might find it helpful thanks and
happy studying